dk wie stabilen muss dieses ding sein
damit es einfach in der luft stehen kann
ein paar sekunden später
hallo mein name ist luca picasso und ich
mach euch heute ein bild die schwester
von max freundin hat mich
freundlicherweise ihren 3d
[Musik]
sie haben auf jeden fall
freundlicherweise bieten 3d pensum louis
camcorder placement zur verfügung
gestellt für dieses video weil ich lust
hatte damit man etwas zu malen
wir haben uns gerade so ein tutorial
dazu angeschaut was eigentlich nur zwei
minuten werbung auf jeden fall haben wir
jetzt erstmal so eine blaue vorhabe da
hinten reingestellt wir haben auch noch
ein paar andere farben hier am start
weil die farbe nämlich nach wieder
rausziehen
da kannst du auch fahren
wir haben das ding hier gerade im
sleep-modus das heißt jetzt mal einfach
hier drauf dann das ist nur wenige
minuten später wir lassen jetzt erst mal
180 grad heizen und wenn er jetzt
leichtfertig ist jetzt nicht gerade bei
150 jetzt steigt gerade hip hop die 160
meiner der anderen seite gespannt wie
ich das erste ding mal okay meine
freunde es geht los
ich zeichne jetzt erst mal luca also ich
gehe hier um dann gehe ich hier so um
die ecke dann stoppe ich ganz kurz dann
fange ich hier wieder an zeichne das
zeigt einfach mal luxury jetzt
tatsächlich als so zäh dann hier dass er
dann machen wir das
daran und das am ende und dann packe
hier um so doch eine herz dran alter
wäre die süße gäste so wird maximale
gerade zumindest man das ganze ab machen
kann das heißt ich fange jetzt mal an
die luxury wirklich hochzuheben mein
gott leute helfe lose l konnte man schon
alleine hoch heben aber ich versuche
jetzt mal dass flugschule hier
tatsächlich alles vermittelt zu haben
das heißt ich nehme das jetzt ganz
vorsichtig hier abnehmen dass wir nehmen
noch dass wir hier mit am start
das herz hinten haben wir noch ich schau
dir dieses herz an
leute wie sie neuerdings die crew die
kurve ökologie wir lassen den stift
jetzt mal einfach wieder auf 180 grad
aufheizen und was ich jetzt probieren
werde ist laut max aussagen möglich das
ganze mit dicker zurzeit ihr damit man
das dann auch abzüge zurück weiterkommen
nach gleich nach den einzeln können ja
soll ich dir dann haben noch ganz oben
nach unten oder so wir sehen gerade
probiert das gehe in einer informativen
zuzufügen
der erfolg scheint sich einzustellen
deswegen produktion würde es schaffen
dass bio kommt auch wieder das herz oder
hat er seine sucht schon nicht mehr so
da ist auch das hörte ich finde das hier
ist jetzt wirklich besser gelungen als
lucas zeichen von vorhin das ist jetzt
zwar ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen
kleiner geworden aber das kurze fangen
jetzt an das luftschiff zeichen so ein
bisschen ab sie ziehen von es geht auf
jeden fall schon viel besser klar als
das wohin der fall war so kurz davor zu
schaffen ich bin halt gerade so kurz
davor ja also hast du nägel dann könnt
ihr das hier an die wand nageln leben ja
nicht krank und niemand weiß schon was
ist gleich wieder wegwerfen hinweg ist
nicht perfekt gerade es dort steht ist
echt geil was man machen könne
also du solltest jetzt den alten fehler
machen und die sache ist der stift
gehört der schwester von matt freundin
will ich jetzt schon zum dritten mal
gesagt haben und deswegen will ich jetzt
nicht den ganzen farben die sich damals
gekauft hat irgendwie wo eigentlich kann
das auch wieder raus willst du den
eiffelturm komplett 3d oder erst mal nur
so oft ich mache einfach mode okay leute
jetzt geht los mit dem abitur
das ist gar nicht so aussieht dass hier
oben ist der fernseher auf dem iphone
drauf er ist kennt ihn nicht den
fernseher auf dem eiffelturm
die scheiße ist wenn eine seite gleich
länger ist als die anderen seiten dann
ist die ganze pyramide ambitionierte
ganz einfach tun aber freunde ich war ja
1938 habe ich ja den internationalen
kunstwettbewerb gewonnen jetzt mancher
tourist in gefahr
deswegen gibt's den eiffelturm derzeit
bisher muss ich sagen es gibt bessern
aber ich bin ja nicht ohne grund der
nutzer also du kannst so ist halt die
abgeschlossen hat auch meine freunde
genau so wurde der it unternehmens
aufgebaut wenn er dann mal drauf geht
müsse man schauen und riechen ihr liegt
wirklich dass er mit dem 3d panel
zusammensetzt wurde alles stahlträger
und das alles nur erfunden und erlogen
ananas in den haag schon nicht besonders
peña ja manchmal noch mehr vielleicht
ich habe ein pickel auf der nase der
zeit passen
die wanderfreunde sie hier drei perfekt
leichte seiten
und hier noch eben kurz rever ihr seht
es kommt nicht mehr so viel raus wenn
ihm auch gleich für den dritten versuch
neue farbe aber ich würde sagen die drei
seiten des eiffelturms sind fertig
natürlich besteht darum eigentlich aus
vier seiten aber deshalb wichtig dass
wenn man ein architekt ist so wie ich
das man wirklich die ganze gebäude die
man je erschaffen hat dass sie auch
funktionieren in der tat zweite seite
vom anbieter muss jetzt auch ab das
heißt wir nehmen jetzt mal die dritte
seite herunter die liste mit ein
bisschen vernünftiger geworden hier so
dass wir möchten die drei seiten was
jetzt einfach mal so dass sich diese
beiden seiten hier festhalte jetzt nehme
ich den stift und haue die hier an
einnahmen
wie man sieht funktioniert nicht immer
hingekriegt das heißt jetzt kommt die
dritte und letzte seite wir jetzt
aneinander kleben werden freunde und
dann haben wir wirklich den perfekten
turnier braucht nämlich gar nicht mehr
so viel weil es hält sich natürlich alle
schon von selbst will ich natürlich als
bahnbrechende architekt perfekte start
die bewiesen habe was macht der mann
etwas mit der rest an alle 3d stift
künstler draußen
ich habe auch an
darf ich jetzt hier hingekriegt haben so
ein eiffelturm zu machen indem wir da
oben das immer noch das schönste
wir nehmen jetzt für das dritte
experiment mal eben die farbe hier raus
und werden eine
für farbe nehmen jetzt endlich mal
wieder fixiert und zwar steckt man dass
sie einfach rein und muster wirklich
alles klar wir stecken jetzt aber mal
die schwarze farbe weiterhin mit rein
und ihr seht schon gleich klappt das
nicht mehr uns war sie mir jetzt am ende
angekommen das heißt nicht brücke jetzt
eben noch das ende von dem blauen raus
jetzt geht das ganze dem ich in die
farbe schwarz silber und was ich jetzt
noch mal versuchen werde ist von hier
einfach einen stumpfen strich nach oben
zu bauen wenn ihr wisst ja freunde zum
titel dieser stift mal 3d kann halt
wirklich einfach so brannte malen dkb
stabilen muss dieses ding seien diese
farbe damit ist einfach in der luft
stehen kann ein paar sekunden später war
es soweit ich werde das ganze jetzt noch
mal probieren allerdings hat wirklich
mit ein bisschen drücke mit
mit dieser ein bisschen halt drücke hin
dass für das war's für das was würdest
du ein perfekter ist jetzt der weg soll
das ist bernd das brot ich werde während
jetzt auch eben hier nur lose vernünftig
einmal also damit es so ein bisschen aus
und das ist noch nicht komplett ab darum
steht wer jetzt hier mal nach oben
versuche ihm jetzt noch vom und hier
dran zumal vielleicht gibt es ja auch
nicht mehr das was wenn ich jetzt noch
etwas in 3d machen würde und das ist
jedoch auch in deine wohnung stellen was
müsste dieses was willst du das dann
sein was soll ich machen ich mein alter
mir habe ich dir jetzt schon gemacht
nicht richtig weiß ich weil ich weiß was
ein paar sekunden später ich finde damit
habe ich jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal
so ein richtiges kunstwerk erschaffen
ich denke jeder weiß dass das ganze
natürlich ein mittelfinger darstellen
soll also ich denke die ähnlichkeit ist
verblüffend und ich finde machst das
perfekt ihr so hin weil das coni super
rein klemmen und wirklich bedeutet auch
zu besuch kommen zudem zeigen hey das
habe ich lebe ich das hat mir blut
afrikas und ist im 3d stift das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne mal leid da
wenn ich demnächst wieder irgendwelche
solche komischen sachen ausprobieren
soll dann schreibe ich auch gern mal die
kommentare dank auch an der stelle an
max fürs film wachsen noch mal ganz kurz
vor die kamera
ihr noch nicht genug von mir kriegen
können findet ihr nun hier eine zweite
eingebildet werde darauf könnte meinen
kanal nämlich kostenlos abonnieren
verpasst keine videos mehr darum dass
ich auf meinen job eingeblendet und hier
unten befindet sich ein weiteres video
clip dann einmal drauf